cuáles éstos son los efectos concretos
de la invasión militar de rusia por
parte de ucrania
con burguilleros
estamos en la ciudad de basic y a 40
kilómetros al sur de la capital
ucraniana y lo que ven en las imágenes
es una escuela que fue alcanzada por un
misil ruso que haití para [__] le paga
misil
total una destrucción total de este
edificio además todavía hay a mis pies
libros escolares abrigos por lo que
podemos imaginar que en el número de
muertos fue un par de docenas
esta es una ciudad que fue golpeada
desde el principio de la ofensiva porque
es una ciudad donde hay tropas
permanentemente y también hay un
aeropuerto militar el objetivo era que
la ofensiva rusa tomara este aeropuerto
para poder avanzar a saltos desde este
aeropuerto hubo una represalia por parte
de las fuerzas ucranianas y muchos
muertos y sabemos que el modus operandi
que tuvo lugar aquí fue un equipo de
saboteadores rusos que estaba infiltrado
es un modus operandi que se ha extendido
mucho desde el inicio de la ofensiva en
las ciudades ucranianas y que atacaba
desde dentro por eso estaba este misil
podemos ver aquí el impacto del incyl y
su violencia
desde la patrona así que hoy esta ciudad
es un frente porque obviamente quiere
estar rodeada casi por completo
sabemos que a pocos kilómetros de donde
estamos está este frente donde se dice
que las fuerzas ucranianas están un poco
abrumada así que sentimos que está
compactadora militar rusa está entrando
en acción
llevamos unos instantes aquí ya hubo
varias sirenas de aviso y bombardeos
aéreos
para los habitantes de este municipio
que se han quedado pues también les
puedo decir que hubo un éxodo masivo y
lo entendemos al ver el grado de
destrucción en el lugar donde estamos en
plena calle
centro de esta ciudad
para los que se quedaron buenos toda la
noche nos dijeron se quedaron en
refugios en sótanos en bodegas porque
había alertas de bombardeo de bomba
y la explosión así que es una situación
precaria y refleja totalmente lo que
está sucediendo aquí en la ciudad de
satélite elop las te quiero que es esta
gran región administrativa que abarca
varios cientos de kilómetros cuadrados
alrededor de quién